Olha essa notícia que acabou de sair e
confesso que me deixou pensando, será
que a COVID pode deixar marcas que
passam pros nossos filhos? Pois é, um
estudo australiano do Instituto Flor
acabou de mostrar algo impressionante.
Eles infectaram camundongos machos com o
vírus da COVID e observaram que isso
causou inflamação nos testículos e
alterou a qualidade do esperma. Até aí
nada muito surpreendente, né? Mas vem o
detalhe importante. Quando esses machos
cruzaram com fêmeas saudáveis, os
filhotes apresentaram mais ansiedade e
reações mais intensas ao estress. E olha
que esses filhotes nunca tiveram contato
com o vírus. O que acontece é o
seguinte: a infecção pode modificar
pequenas moléculas de RNA no esperma que
funcionam como instruções genéticas
paraa formação da próxima geração. É
como se o corpo guardasse uma memória
molecular do que passou. Agora calma.
Isso foi em camundongos. Ainda não temos
evidência clara de que aconteça da mesma
forma em humanos, mas o estudo acende um
alerta importante sobre como infecções
podem deixar marcas mais profundas do
que a gente imaginava. Então fica a
reflexão. Cuidar da nossa saúde hoje
pode significar proteger não só a gente,
mas potencialmente as próximas gerações
também. Vale pensar nisso.